elle représente le futur mais sur ce
plateau jurassien l'apparition des
éoliennes géantes aura aussi contribué à
financer un curieux voyage dans le temps
c'est un petit plaisir oui d'avoir
d'avoir le bâtiment dans l'état où il
est maintenant quand on a connu il ya
seulement quatre ans la chapelle
saint-jacques date du 16e siècle il
fallait la sauver et il fallait le faire
vite
[Musique]
là où on est comme il a plu les jours
précédents là on sort avec un parapluie
parce qu'il pleuvait autant dehors trois
jours après la pluie continue pleuvoir
l'intérieur de la chapelle
donc ça n'allait pas durer longtemps
longtemps la chapelle qui était une
propriété privée a servi de remise ou
d'ateliers tout était à refaire
heureusement l'état et les collectivités
locales notamment au pot financer ce
projet de rénovation impossible pour le
village de 170 habitants de payer seuls
la note près de huit cent cinquante
mille euros
il y en a qui n'étaient pas d'accord sur
le coût d'une telle restauration alors
que certains n'ont pas de quoi se loger
mais bon c'est un an n'est pas sage là
et puis ce ce monument c'est quand même
une trace de l'histoire
si on l'avait laissée s'effondrer même
fois plus personne n'avait le choix de
la restaurer que là on a fait notre on a
fait notre boulot à un moment donné ce
qu'ils voudront danse entendre 100 ans
ils veulent pas continuer la mémoire
s'arrêteront stéphane pianais lui aussi
connaît très bien ce lieu unique
son grand père l'utilisait parfois pour
entreposer les fromages avec d'autres
aujourd'hui il veut faire revivre cette
chapelle de l'exposition du champ parce
que l'acoustique est là de la musique
voilà pour faire simple mais on se donne
aucune on veut s'ouvrir
voilà on veut s'ouvrir on lance un appel
à tous ceux qui veulent venir partager
et faire évoluer le site
donc on est fermé à rien voilà mais
c'est vrai que la culture et l'art c'est
le point commun
beaucoup de communes rêveraient de
pouvoir restaurer leur patrimoine comme
on l'a fait ici
mais attention même achat molle on
reconnaît qu'aujourd'hui ce projet
pourrait ne jamais aboutir
[Musique]